bon alors on va faire une interview
oui qui va vous permettre d'enfin parler
de vous tu peux parler normalement il
entend y compris oui tout d'un coup j'ai
la maison qui croient que c'est charles
vanel non il tenir dans un sac chanel
fait un quart d'heure extraordinaire on
va parler de lui maintenant à faire une
interview miroir méline
jean-claude mais il ressemble à quoi
l'homme que vous voyez dans ce miroir
il faudrait qu'ils perdent 15 kg il en a
vu beaucoup des vertes et des pas mûres
il a les cheveux blancs parce qu'il se
fait du souci temps en temps puis voilà
vous donnez quel âge comme ça moi je
n'aime pas donner d âge et qu'il est
entre 60 et 70 ans
vous trouvez comment cet homme je ne
m'aime pas moi j'aime pas me regarder
il y avait beaucoup de films j'ai pas vu
de moi contiennent des missions de des
gens que j'ai enregistrée qui passa
tueur je regarde pas donc ne nous mettez
pas un miroir en face de massy justement
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît pas dans cet
homme si je ne m'aimais pas je vivrai
pas avec moi je me serais suicidé depuis
longtemps de je m'accepte mais enfin je
me trouve parfois brillant drôle méchant
gourmands
cet homme que vous voyez où vous voulez
pas regarder le re ya que les imbéciles
qui sont heureux comment on peut être
heureux quand le matin vous mettez votre
radio moi jamais de tôt le matin on
l'entend qu'à la guerre en irak qui a la
palestine qui a les élections on bouge
qui a le sida qui a des enfants qui
meurent de faim vous pouvez être heureux
il reste la drogue l'alcool et les
tranquillisants voilà alors moi je me
drogue pas et je le prends pas de
tranquillisants il a l'air très polis
comme ça vous pensez qu'il peut dire des
gros mots cet homme il dit des gros mots
et puis les révoltés surtout n'est pas
du tout une pépère à six qui bouge pas
d'après vous c'est quoi son métier oh
c'est beau comme on appelle ça compteur
baratineur il aime bien parler
il aurait pu faire autre chose comme
métier avocat vous êtes un peu la même
chose mais ils gagnent plus d'argent
clientèle qui est fidèle
vous l'aimez bien cet homme oui vous le
regardez pas souvent non
quand même quand je me maquille aux
cadres je fais très vite
ouais c'est quoi la différence
principale entre l'homme que vous voyez
dans le miroir et vous n'y en a pas un
n'a pas je ne vois pas de différence
vous est-ce que les et cocteau les
miroirs devrait réfléchir deux fois
avant de renvoyer leur image
les gx aux éditions
m